have you ever wondered what iconic
twilight scenes would look like
if movie magic hadn't interfered without
the help of cgi
many of our favorite franchises most
iconic scenes would look
pretty silly twilight is no exception
with all the fantastical fight scenes
drastic aging of characters throughout
the films
and many actors seeming to seamlessly
transition from human to werewolf
let's break down how some of the
twilight franchise's famous scenes were
brought to life
in twilight one of the hallmark traits
of a vampire
is their glittering skin when it catches
the sunlight that's like diamonds
ilm the special effects team also owned
by lucasfilm
was able to add in the extra sparkle on
pattinson's face
in post-production in new moon prime
focus vfx was responsible for making
edward sparkle
visual effects supervisor eric
pascarelli explains the process
there was a very delicate balance of the
elements that make up the effect
we use 3d particle geometry dispersed
over a cg model of edward's head to
reflect several artificial environments
in order to create the sparkles and rays
one of the most romantic and
exhilarating moments for bella early on
in the relationship
is jumping through trees with edward you
better hold on tight spider monkey
in the movie it looks easy enough but
sparing no expense
the producers of twilight didn't want to
only rely on cgi for these moments
the visual effects team led by richard
kidd had to install
a support rig that was about 100 feet
tall and spanning three large pine trees
it was four pipes that created the
structure like a box
and they snap together like lego pieces
kids said
the rig wasn't only for studying the
natural pine trees but also used to hold
the winches and pulleys used to carry
the actors and crew
up and down from the trees once the
filming was finished
the visual effects team had to go back
and digitally remove the rig
cables and harness used on the actors
which required a lot of meticulous work
on the editor's end
generally considered sombre films the
twilight series offers moments of levity
the vampire baseball scene in the first
twilight movie is a great example
vampire baseball is just like regular
baseball
but a lot cooler to make the actors seem
as if they were practically flying they
were attached to a harness that would
move them around
in correlation to their marks the cast
also had to strut on a grass-covered
moving walkway to give the illusion of a
supernaturally speedy
vampire gate nobody can't forget that
epic
moment when we got to see jacob
transform from a teenager to a full-on
werewolf
while looking effortless practically
graceful on screen
there was a lot of work that went into
each of those transformations
the giant werewolves were all created
using cgi
and actor taylor lautner's already
filmed scenes were used for reference
launtner was hooked up to a harness to
simulate him jumping off into werewolf
form
and then a werewolf was built around
that and then added into the movie in
post-production
we all love bella for her quiet nature
open heart
and overall relatability but we also
love her because she's a strong woman
who sticks up for herself
we see in a scene in new moon a heated
confrontation about jacob
ends in bella punching paul making him
turn into his werewolf form
at first glance the scene looks like a
pretty easy one
but actress kristen stewart had to
rehearse that punch with a stunt
coordinator
and then coordinate the timing and the
moves out with the other actors
this scene also showed the audience
another graceful transformation from
human to werewolf by paul
eclipse has one of the most thrilling
and epic action scenes in the entire
franchise
the chase scene with victoria to
simulate jumping off of rocks
the actors were hooked up to a harness
attached to the ceiling of a filming
studio
where they would have to jump on green
screen boulders that were just green
ledges and steps
the actors were also filmed running on
what the production crew
called magic carpets that would make it
appear that they were running a lot
faster than they actually were
a tender moment shared between bella and
jacob in werewolf form
is right before the big battle scene
against victoria and her newborns
against the cullens and the werewolves
in eclipse
in the movie werewolf jacobs saddles up
to bella and she gives him a sweet
scratch on the head
which was all edited in post-production
to look like she was scratching a real
werewolf
while filming actor taylor lautner was
dressed in a non-reflective bodysuit and
hat
and he stood in where his werewolf self
would be in the movie
kristen stewart went as far as
scratching taylor's head while filming
werewolf or human in a bodysuit it's
still pretty sweet
the way the production staff were able
to make it seem like actress mackenzie
foy was
actually riding on the back of jacob in
werewolf form
is pretty complicated they had mackenzie
sit on a motion control rig
a machine that resembles a mechanical
bull with a saddle covered in werewolf
jacob's fur
the rig was set against a green screen
and pre-programmed with all the moves to
resemble jacob running
and mackenzie sat on it while they
filmed her with a wind machine blowing
so it looked like she was moving fast
the animators at tipit studio started by
going to the actual lumber yard and
getting footage there
then built the whole scene starting with
the dialogue from the actors from a
recording
tippit studios actually had helicopters
flown over the area with cameras so they
could get an
aerial view then they created a
storyboard deciding the shots
and once they were approved to move
forward they started working on
animating the wolves against the
real-life lumber yard backdrop
baby renesme was originally meant to be
a to scale animatronic doll
but the producers deemed it too scary to
use
and the actors never looked comfortable
acting against it
the animatronic version had full length
hair and giant
unnatural looking eyes even for a half
vampire half human
instead the producers decided to use cgi
a rubber baby doll and an actual human
baby to create
every aspect of baby resume which has
garnered better
but not great reviews from fans and
audiences alike
there were several options on how the
production team could choose to make
renesme age at a superhuman rate in
breaking dawn part 2
and they chose to use lola visual
effects to reimagine mckenzie as
renesmee from birth up until her age at
the end of the series
utilizing baby photos of mackenzie the
effects team was able to create an
accurate chart of what renesme would
look like at any age
and they used actual babies as physical
stand-ins while
shooting sounds pretty intense but the
payoff was worth it
the twilight saga and snow go together
like peanut butter and jelly in fans
minds
and it's fitting that the final battle
with the volturi is beautifully set with
a snow-capped background
but when actually filming the actors and
crew were inside a production studio
where there were green screen backdrops
and
fake snow grounds the camera crew rode
on a vehicle
while the actors had to run towards or
away from it in the snow
the pregnancy and eventual birth scenes
in the breaking dawn movies were one of
the few times we really got to
experience the horror and romance
aspects at its peak in twilight
to make kristen stewart look as
emancipated and frail as she did in the
movie
she went through extensive makeup and
even face prosthetics to really give the
full look
also the fx team actually built a
life-sized doll of kristen that they
used when edward was giving her cpr
kristen's actual body was underneath the
bed with the dummy on top
the final battle in eclipse is visually
breathtaking
seeing beautiful powerful people and
werewolves run around
in a snow-covered forest definitely
gives viewers a treat
believe it or not the battle in the snow
was filmed inside of a production studio
where a full-size set of the forest was
built where they couldn't use practical
effects
such as trees and fake snow a green
screen behind the set was utilized in
post-production to give it that winter
wonderland feel
one of the first times bella and the
audience gets to witness some of
edward's supernatural abilities
are in the intense action scene where
bella is almost hit by tyler's van
thankfully edward who was across the
parking lot sped to her rescue and
stopped the moving van with his hand
leaving a sizable dent they were able to
make this happen by replacing the
original passenger side door with a soft
molded door that would easily move under
robert pattinson's hand
we think those scenes are still iconic
with or without the green screens and
harnesses being visible
and we can't imagine the twilight
franchise without them
what do you think do the twilight movies
still maintain their magic
even without all the supernatural cgi
and fx added in by hollywood
let us know in the comments